say I've got a subspace V so V is some
subspace some subspace some subspace
maybe of r-n I'm going to define the
orthogonal complement of V let me write
that down the orthogonal orthogonal
complement complement of V is the set
and this is a shorthand notation right
here would be the orthogonal complement
of V so we write this little orthogonal
notation as a superscript on V and you
can pronounce this is V perp not for a
purpose not for perpetrator but or
perpendicular so V perp the perp is
equal to is equal to the set of all X's
all X all the vectors X that are a
member of our RN that are member of our
RN such that X dot V X dot V is equal to
0 for every or every vector V that is a
member of our subspace so we're
essentially saying look you have some
subspace it's got a bunch of vectors in
it now if I can find some other set of
vectors where every member of that set
is orthogonal to every member of U the
subspace in question then the set of
those vectors is called the orthogonal
complement of V the orthogonal
complement of V and you write it this
way V perp right there so the first
thing that we just tend to do and we're
you know defining a space or defining
some set is to see hey is this a
subspace is V perp or the orthogonal
complement of V is this a subspace
subspace
well you might remember from many many
videos ago that we had just a couple of
conditions for a subspace that if if
let's say that a and B are both a member
of V perp then
we have to wonder whether a plus B is a
member of V perp that's our first
condition it needs to be it needs to be
closed under addition in order for this
to be a subspace and then the next
condition is well if a if a is a member
of V perp is some scalar multiple of a
also a member also a member of V perp
and then the last one it has to contain
the zero vector which is a little bit
redundant with this because if any
scalar multiple of a is a member of V of
our orthogonal complement of V they
could just multiply it by zero so it
would imply that the zero vector is a
member of V so what is what is this
imply what is the fact that a and B are
members of V perp that means that that
means that a dot V where this V is any
member of our original subspace V is
equal to zero for any for any V that is
a member of our subspace V and it also
means that B since V is also a member of
V perp that V dot any member of our
subspace is also going to be zero for
any V that is a member of V so what
happens what happens if we take a plus B
dot V let's do that so if I do a plus B
dot V what is this going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to a dot V
plus B dot V and we just said the fact
that both a and B are members of our
orthogonal complement means that both of
these quantities are going to be equal
to zero so this is going to be equal to
zero plus zero which is equal to zero so
a plus B is definitely a member of our
thought candle complement so we got our
check box right there doing a different
color than the question mark check for
the first condition for being a subspace
now is ca a member of V perp well let's
just take C if we take C a and dot it
with any member of our original subspace
and even
original subspace this is the same thing
as C times a dot V and what is this
equal to by definition a was a member of
our orthogonal complement so this is
going to be equal to zero so it's going
to be C times zero which is equal to
zero so this is also a member of our
orthogonal complement to V and of course
I could multiply C times zero and I
would get to zero or you could just say
look zero is orthogonal to everything
you take the zero vector and dot it with
anything you can get zero so the zero
vector is always going to be a member of
any orthogonal complement because it
obviously is always going to be true for
this condition right here so we know we
know that V perp or the orthogonal
complement of V is is a subspace is a
subspace which is nice because now we
can apply to it all of the properties
that we know of subspaces now the next
question and I touched on this in the
last video I said I kind of just touched
on the idea I said that though if I have
some matrix a if I have some matrix a
and you know let's just say it's an M by
n matrix in the last video I said that
the row space of a the row space of a is
well let me write it this way I wrote
that the null space of a switch the
order the null space of a the null space
of a is equal to the orthogonal
complement is the orthogonal orthogonal
orthogonal complement complement of the
row space of the row space row space of
a and in the way that we can write the
row space of a this thing right here the
row space of a is the same thing as the
column space of a transpose so one way
you could write rewrite this sentence
right here is that the null space of a
the null space of a is the orthogonal
complement of the row space the row
space is the column space of the
transpose matrix and the claim which I
have not proven to you is that this is
the orthogonal complement of this so
this is equal to that the little perp
the little perpendicular superscript
that's the claim and at least in the
particular example that I did in the
last two videos this was the case where
I actually showed you that 2 by 3 matrix
but let's see if this applies generally
if this applies generally so let's let
me write my matrix a like this so my
matrix a I can write it as just a bunch
of row vectors but just to be consistent
with our notation with our notation what
vectors we tend to associate as column
vectors so that so to represent the row
vector so I'm going to write them as
transpose vectors because in our reality
vectors will always be column vectors
and row vectors are just transposes
those are 1 transpose our to transpose
and you go all the way down we have M
rows so you're going to get RM RM
transpose don't let the transpose part
confuse you I'm just saying that these
are row vectors these are row vectors
I'm writing transposes there just to say
that look these are the transposes of
column vectors that represent these rows
but all I'm but if it's helpful for you
to imagine I'm just imagine this is the
first row of that guy of the matrix this
is the second row of that matrix so on
and so forth now what is the null space
of a well that's all of the vectors here
let me do it like this the null space of
a is let me write it like this I love
it's all of the vectors X that satisfy
the equation this is going to be equal
to the zero vector now to solve this
equation what can we do we've seen this
multiple times this matrix vector
product is essentially the same thing as
saying let me actually let me write it
like this a little bit let me write it
like this
we're it's going to be equal to 0 vector
in RM you're going to have a m 0
all the way down to the M zero so
another way to write this equation
you've seen it before is this you when
you take the matrix vector product
you're essentially taking the dot
product so to get to this entry right
here this entry right here is going to
be this row dotted with my vector X so
this is our one we're calling this row
vector R 1 transpose as the transpose of
some column vector that can represent
that row but that dot dot my vector X
not my vector X this vector X is going
to be equal to that 0 now if I take this
guy let me do it in a different color if
I take this guy and I dot him with
vector X is going to be equal to that 0
so R 2 transpose dot X dot X is going to
be equal to that 0 right there so by
definition or I guess let me write it
this way another way to write this
equation another way to write this
equation is that is that R 1 dot X right
this way
R 1 transpose X is equal to 0 R 2
transpose X is equal to 0 all the way
down to RN transpose X is equal to 0 and
by definition the null space of a the
null space of a is equal to all of the
X's all of the X's that are members of
well in this case it's an M by n matrix
you're going to have n columns so it's
all the X's that are members of our n
such that ax is equal to 0 or you can
alternately write it this way
that you if you were to dot each of the
rows with X you're going to be equal to
0 so you could write it this way you
could well let me just write such that a
X is equal to 0 that's an easier way to
write it so let's think about it so if
someone is a member if by definition I
give you some vector V if I say that let
me switch colors
if I tell you if I were to tell you that
V is a member is a member of the null
space of a I just tell you let's call it
V 1 V 1 is a member of null space of a
that means it satisfies this equation
right here that means a times V is equal
to 0 a times V is equal to 0 means that
when you dot each of these rows with V
you get equal to 0 or another way to
saying that is that V 1 is orthogonal
orthogonal to all of these rows to r1
transpose that's just the first row R 2
transpose all the way to R M all the way
to RM transpose so this is orthogonal to
all of these guys by definition any
member of the null space well if you're
thuggin 'el to all of these members of
God all of these rows in your matrix
you're also orthogonal to any linear
combination of them right you're also
orthogonal to any linear combination
orthogonal to any linear combination
combination I mean you could imagine
let's say that we have some vector that
is a linear combination of these guys
right here so let's say vector let me
write it let me just write it well let
me it's going to be a member of the r
space let me think of a good now I want
to do a different let's say a vector
let's say vector W vector W is equal to
some linear combination of these vectors
right here I wrote them as transpose
it's just because they're row vectors
but I can just write them as regular
column vectors just to show that W is
just could be just a regular column
vector so let's say W is equal to c1
times r1 plus c2 times R 2 all the way
to C M times R M that's what W is equal
to so what happens when you take V which
is a member our null space and u dotted
with W
so if you take if we were to take V and
dotted with W it's going to be V dotted
with each of these guys because our dot
product has the distributive property so
if u dot V with each of these guys it's
going to be equal to c1 I'm just going
to take the scalar out c1 times V dot R
one plus c2 times V V dot R two this is
an R right here not a V plus all the way
to plus cm times V dot R M and we know
we already just said that V dot L each
of these RS are going to be equal to
zero so all of these are going to be
equal to zero so this whole expression
is going to be equal to zero so if you
have any vector that's a linear
combination of these row vectors if you
dotted with any member of your null
space you're going to get zero so this
so let me write it this way what is any
vector that's any linear combination of
these guys well that's the span of these
guys or you could say that the row space
that's the row space so if you take if W
is a member of the row space which you
can just represent as a column space of
a transpose then we know we know and and
let's say we know that V V is a member
of our null space we know that V dot W
is going to be equal to zero I just
showed that to you right there so every
member of our null space is definitely
orthogonal to every member of our row
space so that's what our we know so far
every member every member of null space
of a is orthogonal agonal to every
member member of
the row space is to the row space of a
now that only gives us half way that
still doesn't tell us that that this is
equivalent to the orthogonal complement
of the null-space for example there
might be members of our orthogonal
complement of the row space that that
aren't in that aren't a member of our
null space so in order to let's let's
say that I have some other vector that
is let's say I have some vector let me
say I have some vector u let's say that
U is a member is a member of the is the
orthogonal complement of our row space I
know the notation is a little convoluted
maybe I should write an R there but I
wanted to keep I want to really get set
in your mind that the row space is just
the column space of the transpose so
let's say that U is some member of our
orthogonal complement what I want to do
is show you that u has to be in your
null space so that when I show you that
then we know so far we just said that ok
then everything in the null space is
orthogonal to the row space but we don't
know that everything that's orthogonal
to the row space which is represented by
this set is also going to be in your
null space that's what we have to show
in order for those two sets to be
equivalent in order for the null space
to be equal to this so if we know this
is true then this means this means that
u dot let's say u dot W where W is a
member of our row space as a member of
our row space is going to be equal to 0
it's going to be equal to 0 let me write
this down
right here that is going to be equal to
0 and what does that mean that means
that means means that u that U is also
orthogonal so this implies that u dot
well you know RJ any of the trends any
of the row vectors any of the row
vectors is also equal to 0 you know
where where J is equal to 1 through all
the way through M how do I know that
well I'm saying that look you take you
as a member of the orthogonal complement
of the row space so that means you is is
orthogonal to any member of your row
space so in particular the basis vectors
of your row space we don't know whether
all of these guys are basis vectors but
that means we can take these guys are
definitely all members of the row space
some of them are actually the basis for
the row space so that means if you take
u dot in any of these guys is going to
be equal to 0 so if you dot any of these
guys is equal to 0 that means that means
that u dot R 1 is 0 let me write this
down
u dot R 1 is equal to 0 u dot R 2 is
equal to 0 all the way to u u dot R M is
equal to 0 well if all of this is true
that means that means that a times the
vector U is equal to 0 that implies this
right you stick you there's you take all
the dot products is going to satisfy
this equation which implies that U is a
member of our null space so we've just
shown you that every member of your null
space is definitely a member of the
orthogonal complement and now we said
that every member of our thuggin
complement is a member of our null space
is a member of our null space and
actually I just notice that I made a
slight error here this dot product I
don't have to write the transpose here
because we've written we've defined our
dot product as the dot product of column
vector so this is the transpose of some
column vector so you can transpose you
can untransparent just take the dot
product but anyway minor error there but
that diverts me from my main takeaway my
punchline the big picture we now showed
you any member of any member of our null
space is a member of the orthogonal
complement so we just showed you this
first statement here is another way of
saying any not member of the null space
or that the null space is a subset of
the orthogonal complement of the row
space so that's our row space and that's
the orthogonal complement of our row
space and here we just showed we just
showed that any member of our any member
of our of the orthogonal complement of
our row space is also a member of your
null space
well these two guys are subsets of each
other they must be equal to each other
so we now know that the null space of a
the null space of a is equal to the
orthogonal complement of the row space
of a or the column space of a transpose
now this is I related the null space
with the row space now I could just as
easily make a bit of a substitution here
let's say that let's say that a is equal
to let's say a is equal to some other
matrix B transpose right it's going to
be the transpose of some matrix you
could transpose either way so if I just
make that substitution here what do we
get we get the null space of B transpose
is equal to the column space of let me
write it out B transpose transpose right
a transpose is B transpose transposed we
get my parentheses right and then that
thing's orthogonal complement so what is
this equal to this the transpose of the
transpose is just equal to B so I could
write it as the null space of B
transpose is equal to the orthogonal
complement of the column space of B Y
orthogonal complement of the column
space of B so just like this we just
showed that the left you know B and a
they're just arbitrary matrices so this
showed us that the null space so this is
null space sometimes it's nice try in
words is orthogonal orthogonal
complement complement of row space of
row space and this right here is showing
us this right here showing us that the
left null space the left null space
which is just the same thing as the null
space of a transpose matrix is equal to
is orthogonal
I'll just shorthand it complement
complement of the column space column
space which are pretty - pretty neat
takeaways we saw a particular example of
it a couple of videos ago and now you
see that it's true for all matrices